Candy Crush is such a fun game did you
see episode one when they stole the
truck and they went down well that was
so cool whoa spoilers guys come on no
that's not really a spoiler that
happened in the first 15 minutes spoiler
spoiler anyways uh it was really good
spoiler guys it's a spoiler that I'm
saying it's good yeah you spoiled that
it's good that's gonna alter my
experience of my but it's gonna alter my
critical judge so when they steal the
truck stop now that's a spoiler it's in
the trailer there's a trailer on a truck
is it like a horse trailer no the
preview oh like a like a preview you
know we're just gonna argue back and
forth it's not going to change anything
spoilers spoiler or a conversation yeah
now I know what you're gonna say and I
like to be surprised wow that's what a
conversation all right you spoiled it
you ruined it we should just stop
talking I'm fine with that actually
let's just not talk anymore this is like
the time Darth Vader ended up being
Luke's father oh spoilers really